hello everyone and welcome to a super
thrilling game uh from defeaths.com
grand swiss it's round eight and uh it's
the leader ever since the tournament
started alireza ferrugia versus evgeny
russian grandmaster and it's a game that
really shows you how you have to play
every game up until the very end and
good things might happen so now let's
check it out that there's quite a lot to
cover uh uh with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 knight to f3 and now
knight to f6 knight goes for the petrov
defense attacking that e for pawn and
usually white will just capture on e5
this is the
most standard plan but here we have d4
this is the steinitz attack against the
petrov defense where black has two very
good options you could capture on d4 or
you could capture an e4 now captures on
d4 is played
on on some occasions but knight captures
on e4 is considered the main move so
this is what nayer plays uh and now you
could continue attacking with bishop to
d3 just challenging this knight but here
just d captures on e5 and now d5 now the
knight is nicely defended and here we
play knight b to d2 now challenge this
knight saying that okay we might capture
this knight and if captures we might
capture here and then uh ruin your
castling privileges but it's a it's very
unlikely that white would do this uh you
know just uh
trading queens like that very early on
uh black goes knight captures on d2 this
is again very very standard move bishop
captures and now bishop to e7 and now
usually you'll just continue with some
like bishop to d3
and then for example c5 and then c3 so
you make some room for your light square
bishop if black decides to attack it but
here alireza goes to c3 right away and
it is already as of move seven that we
have a completely new game but not
really as we're going to transpose in um
into some very very popular games so
this is not actually a new move so here
we have c5 and now bishop to d3 so just
a different move order knight to c6 and
now we have castles we have bishop to g4
now pinning the knight preparing knight
captures and e5 so of course rook to e1
we have to guard our pawn here queen to
d7 nire develops the queen connects uh
will almost connects the rook so you
have the castle first and uh here you'll
be able to cast the king side or queen
side depending on
what kind of a game you're interested in
playing so here h3 asking do you want to
capture do you want to move back what do
you want to do so bishop to h5 and now
bishop to f4 uh improving the activity
of the bishop and also now uh our pawn
is also protected many times so queen to
e6 and now comes bishop to e2 now uh the
knight is no longer pinned and we can
freely move the queen around so narrow
castles here and queen to d2 uh so what
uh what uh what can black play here well
the bishop no longer serves any purpose
here so uh he moves it to g6 now
controls this long diagonal and now rook
a to d1 and it seems the white has
finished development black has yet to
develop both of the rooks uh so bishop
to e for now uh defending the spawn
after rook to d1 the pawn was hanging so
bishop here defends the pawn and now
knight the g5 here alireza says all
right i'm now winning your bishop pair
uh either i'm gonna capture the light
square bishop or you can capture with
the dark square bishop so black captures
and g5 with bishop captures on g5 and
the position has been reached before um
last time he was reached it was in the
2019 uh feeder grand prix between wesley
so and you young gee wesley won that
game yangi played h6 here but here we
have d4 by night and it is now as of
move 17 that we really have a completely
new game and it's completely new
unexplored territory so here uh what do
you play uh well it's very unlikely that
you want to capture here if you capture
here black just puts a knight on d4 and
how are you getting rid of this knight
it's a it's a very annoying piece so of
course we're not going to do that uh
here um alireza just brings the bishop
back all the way to f1 and now asks all
right what do you play here well here we
have queen to g6 putting pressure on the
bishop for the moment the queen defends
the bishop but uh
white has to be very careful so queen to
f4 now attacking the bishop on e4 twice
and what do you do with this bishop well
you could move it to d5 for example but
if you play bishop to d5 it's uh
maybe not uh
not not doing all that great it's
undefended there you're very restricted
in what you can do this bishop might be
hanging at some point and the white will
get uh some uh free moves in like for
example bishop to d3 now the bishop rook
to d3 narrow can come to g3 and it could
be very annoying so instead bishop the
c2 is played now attacking the rook
still preventing any any rook lifts here
and now rook to d2 attacking the bishop
and now rook ate the e8 asking uh what
do you do now so here we have bishop to
h4 now the queen can move also the
bishop will not be
on g5 if the white queen ever moves then
you can shift the bishop to g3 at any
moment
to add more defense to your e5 pawn so
here we have king to h8 and now we have
f3 this was a very interesting position
for
for alireza is there was this very
interesting bishop to b5 move now saying
okay you can't move the knight because
your rook hangs and well now if c
captures on d4 you're not going to be
able to capture with the knight you're
going to have to capture with this spawn
and it's going to be very weak so how
are you really defending this pawn so
here we would probably see something
like d captures on c3 and after b
captures uh it's still a very very
difficult position to play because once
the bishop captures the queen will have
to capture or rather the queen will not
be able to capture the queen has to keep
an eye on the bishop on c2 you're going
to have to capture with the pawn so
let's sound like a6 captures you're
going to have to capture with the b pawn
and then even rook d6 is a possibility
and if rook to e6 for example now bishop
to g3 and it's a a very very nice
position for white with black's
structure uh here on the queen side uh
uh somewhat dubious uh but okay after
king h8 uh uh furuja decided to go for
f3 and now we have a6 and this is uh
this gives white uh
some chances of improving the position
d3 was very interesting here as now this
pawn cannot really be captured it's
defended many times you can also add
more more support to the pawn not for
the moment the bishop is covering the
eight but you could uh
if it was uh if it was really needed for
example even f6 might be an idea at some
point but uh it would just be a very
very uh strong move and it would really
restrict the movement of white's pieces
but instead uh we have a6 by black and
now uh of course preventing this bishop
to b5 idea that we were discussing and
now bishop to f2 now saying okay now
you're not playing pawn to d3 i'm just
going to capture your opponent c5 and
the situation on the clock here is 20
minutes for all it is and 25 minutes for
evgeny and it's only moved 23. so 17
more moves need to be played in order to
reach time control so here we have rook
to d8 and now rook the c1 further
harassing this bishop here so bishop to
b1 attacking the a2 pawn uh but now just
c captures on d4 and here alireza went
really really low on the clock he's
already three minutes
on the clock and he still has to play 15
more moves in order to reach time
control um uh so what do you play
instead of c captures on d4 you could uh
play something like a3 and okay your
pawn will not be attacked but then you
play knight a5 and you've allowed this
knight to get to this b3 square you
really don't want to allow this
another thing you could have played is
b3 and the rook will be nicely defending
the pawn uh but then you simply allow
black to trade down and that's really
what black wants to wants to do rook
captures on c3 we can capture on d2
queen captures on d2 and now for example
rook to d8 and black is very very happy
here so uh alireza's idea seems to be
the most promising c captures on d4 and
now if you go c captures on d4 uh then
we're just going to play a4 get rid of
our target on a2 and then we're gonna
capture this pawn it's attacked many
times black will not be able to defend
it so black instead decided to capture
with the knight not with the pawn after
c capture so knight captures on d4
bishop captures on d for c captures and
now a3 so the pawn is still a target and
you can't really defend it if you play
some like queen to b6 you no longer
guard the bishop on b1 so that's not
possible so here we have bishop to a2
and now yeah alireza just grabs the pawn
with rook captures on d4 as maybe a
slight improvement could also be
something like b4 as you know why not uh
maybe uh
it serves some purpose because you know
white wastes the opportunity of playing
b4 with tempo now the bishop is attacked
and once the bishop moves then we
collect the pawn so maybe just throwing
in that b4 but okay well it is a place
where captures on d4 right away and now
queen to b6 now pinning this rook so how
do you defend here rook to d1 and now
rook f2 e8 and now we absolutely have to
unpin here so king to h2 and now we have
rook captures on d4 getting rid of one
of the rooks queen captures on d4 queen
capture sunday for and the rook captures
on d4 and unfortunately for black uh he
can't reclaim the pawn because if rook
captures then you just get checkmated
rook to d8 to check rookie 8 recapture
signing a to checkmate so we have to do
something about this here black plays g5
creates some breeding room for the king
and also prevents white's a very
important f4 move at the really uh you
know cemented that pawn on e5 so here we
have rook to d7 all it is this is okay
you capture on e5 i'm gonna start
capturing along the seventh rank okay
not to this one obviously but the b7 is
hanging so black first place b5 and now
rook to d6 going after the a6 spawn and
now you can't
push those pawns because then the the b5
pawn falls so here we have a trade rook
captures on an e5 rook captures an a6
and now bishop to c4 now defending the
b5 pawn but you also have to trade down
your bishop so bishop captures on c4 b
captures on c4 and now a4 so this is the
position um
a rook end game where white is up upon
and white has a past a pawn so can white
make something of this he's only up one
pawn and as you guys know in rook end
games that's uh not not a lot uh so
let's see how the game continues rook
the c5 black wants to eliminate this
pawn and then fight against the
uh the the past a4 pawn so rook to b6
and now c3 with b captures and c3 rook
captures and now a5 so uh alireza wants
to push this pawn to victory but of
course this rook can always get behind
the pass pawn so when you're pushing to
victory you want your own rook behind
your pass pawn and of course black wants
his own rook behind the pass pawn so
king g7 we have to activate our kings we
have a6 now and rook to a3 of course
we're not gonna allow white to put the
rook behind the pass pawn king the g3
and now rook to a2 uh we have f4 uh
trading off this uh pawn for this uh
well sort of a weak pawn and now g
captures on f4 now this also means that
alireza has to give up one pawn in order
to make some progress here king captures
on f4 and now rook captures on g2 and
now the material is equal so black won
back his pawn but alireza has a bit of a
more active king so here we have king to
e5 and now what do you do with the rook
uh do you go after this pawn or do you
put your rook behind the pass pawn yeah
what do you think is is best here well
of course it's best to go behind the
pass pawn going after the h3 pawn would
actually loses the game just to give you
a quick demonstration king d6 rook
captures on h3 king c6 and now we're not
in time rook to a3 we're gonna play king
to b7 and once uh black starts pushing
we don't care just a7 we're gonna
promote to a queen and after let's say
we trade here uh we we have all the time
in the world to prevent this you can't
over push this pawn because we can
simply attack it and the the king will
not be able to capture it uh
to catch up to the pawn we can easily
you know just grab it so you're gonna
have to play some like f6 king b7 uh
king to g6 king to c6 and now after some
like h4 you start pushing king d5 you're
gonna play king g5 king to e4 and for
checking f3 and you can see that uh
white is very very much in time uh so
after king e5 rook the 80 was played
this is this is best uh and now king to
d6 we have f5 uh black's absolute best
move you have to start pushing that pass
pawn king to c7 we have f4 king to b8
and now
we have f3 so a7 by alireza and now f2
black also ready to promote this pawn to
a queen and here alireza plays rook to
b1 and now is uh the the well the this
beautiful moment in the game where black
can uh either you know continue playing
uh best moves or black can blunder the
game uh so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the
uh
the best way for black not to lose this
game while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
you have to start marching with the king
so the king going down the board is the
only way to save this game and i will
demonstrate why in the game uh actual uh
this move was played upon the f1 queen
uh to
start start the race but it doesn't work
just uh to show you why you have to
start going down with your king it
doesn't really matter which square you
use and now after a8 queen and the rooks
get traded off or rather the queen is
captured king captures an eight now king
g5 and now the existence of the pawn on
f2 will force this rook to remain on the
first rank in order to capture it for
example rook to f1 king h4 we're now
going to capture on f2 and now king
captures an h3 and now this is a draw
the the rook alone cannot stop this pawn
because if you attack it we're just
going to push it and once it gets to the
king it's a draw and if you try
something like rook to f5 to prevent it
from
reaching h5 we're first going to kick it
away with king g4 and only then push at
h5 so that's not going to work and it's
very easy king b7 just h5 we're going to
play king to c6h for king d5 and now
king to g3 it's a very very simple rook
f7 h3 after king e4 we're going to play
h2 and that's it after one check we're
going to play king f2 and now after rook
h7 came to g1 and now we either get a
queen into the game or white has to just
continue checking us if king f3 of
course this is just an instant draw this
is promoted with check now captures
captures and will we would have a draw
by insufficient material but after rook
to b1 uh knight played f1 queen and it
seems like the race uh
is identical but it's not because now uh
after alireza captures the queen uh you
don't really have rook captures on a7
because now after king captures an a7 uh
the white rook doesn't have to you know
play rook to fond then rook captures on
f2 and the black king is behind too many
tempi king h6 we're gonna play h4 even
and after king h5 just rook f4 and
you're never getting that uh pawn off
the board we can just move our rook uh
the the pawn will never be able to be
pushed and we can just you know use all
the time in the world to bring our king
into the game so instead after rook
captures an f1 rook to b to check was
played but now king to a8 rook to b3
going after the pawn but now rook to c1
you no longer have to
take care of the pawn uh so here we have
king to g6 black has to you know start
starts doing something and now rook to
c7 uh so we're gonna block
the b file with a rook get the king away
from the a file and then promote our
pawn to a queen and now again if you
capture the pawn now it doesn't really
matter we're just going to play rook c6
check king to g5 and after king to b7
that's it rook to b3 check we're going
to play rook to b6 and after rook a3
just rook to a6 and after uh rook to b3
check we're just going to move our king
king to c7 king to c6 doesn't really
matter after the king is checked we're
going to go back it's important that we
do not allow the the black rook to give
itself up for the pawn so here rook to
d3 we're gonna move here look here we're
gonna move here and after rook here
we're gonna move here there are no more
checks and the next move will bring the
queen into the game and win this uh well
uh very very hard for default game so
after rook the c7 we have h5 uh but now
rook to b7 uh and again now if rook to
a3 uh just king to b8 and after king to
g5 we can simply play rook to b4 and you
can never cross this uh next movie just
uh bring your queen into the game black
has to give up the rook and that's it
so after rook to b7 uh rook captures an
h3 was played but it is uh all uh much
too late for such things so rugby six
check king g5 now king to b7 and it's
pretty much the same idea the white king
will be able to hide uh behind the black
king in order to avoid all the checks so
rook a3 rook to a6 we have rook to b3
check and now king to c7 and he was in
this position on move 59 that uh evgeny
and i resigned to the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here uh so
it's uh
the exact same thing now if we continue
checking the king we're just gonna run
away and hide behind the black king and
that's it rook f3 check king g6 a king
g7 and that's it next movie bring the
queen into the game and of course you
you have no way of of playing this
anymore with black
so really really
incredible game and it really shows you
how you have to play apps you know every
every game up until the very end in
order to win games like these because if
again in our is a very strong
grandmaster and of course many other
players would just agree of course we
have three pawns each that's a draw
let's call it a day and we play another
game tomorrow
but as you know magnus would grind as
bobby fischer would grind it seems
alireza also enjoys grinding and he
grinds down a very strong russian
grandmaster here which also means that
he is now the sole leader after eight
runs we're also gonna uh discuss the
standings a little bit uh here they are
um
so the top of the the top of the
standings uh ferruja in first place with
five and a half out of seven followed by
uh three people with five maximum shell
grav krishna sikran and alexey shirov
and then uh a lot of people with with
four and a half and four points so uh do
he's doing great so far uh four more
rounds to go he's the sole leader of the
of the grand swiss and if uh he plays
those four rounds well uh well he gets
uh he gets into uh the next cycle of
defeated candidates tournament which
means that uh well uh if he wins it and
he you know uh goes up uh to challenge
the world champion and magnus or nippo
in this case for for the title we could
be looking at our youngest uh world
chess champion ever i believe as he's
currently 18 and i don't think
um
i don't think uh
or rather i don't know
when the next cycle will be like
some people are saying that the next
candidates okay maybe we'll be in 2022
and then maybe even the world
championship will be in 2022 some are
saying that it will be shifted to 2023
so who knows with everything what's
happening in the world but he is
definitely on uh on on a nice path but
we'll see what happens uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it a bit
of a longer one but uh and games are
like that uh i would like to thank lucas
de ocaries um
uh james mayberry uh abdul el traore
frank comes and david lille for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day